some Democratic lawmakers in California
want to make it the first state to
significantly restrict when police
officers can open fire the proposed
legislation is in direct response to
last month's deadly police shooting of
Stephan Clark he was not armed at the
time Carter Evans is at the California
State Capitol with more on this story
Carter good morning to you good morning
lawmakers want to raise the standard for
when police can use deadly force from
when it's considered too reasonable to
only when it is absolutely necessary to
preserve human life they believe that'll
encourage officers to defuse more
situations but others believe it could
put police lives in danger of grief
tensions remain high in Sacramento more
than two weeks after the police shooting
of 22 year old Stephan Clark at a City
Council meeting Tuesday community
members demanded answers and action you
better give us justice cuz you're damn
sure not ready for what comes next those
cries for justice and reform have now
spread from Sacramento City Hall to the
State Capitol the time is now to act
time for California to step up
California lawmakers plan to introduce
new legislations raising the standard
for when police officers can use deadly
force in the six seconds between the
time officers called out to Stephan
Clark and opened fire current California
law required them to determine whether
the use of deadly force was quote
reasonable but the new law would require
them to determine whether it's not just
reasonable but necessary this policy
authorizes police office to use deadly
force only when it is necessary to
prevent eminent and serious bodily
injury or death this is a split-second
decision in many cases it's not only a
split-second decision but it's a
critical one that'll last forever
Assemblymember and former California
Highway Patrol officer Tom Lackey says
changing the deadly 4 standard could put
an unreasonable burden on officers
caught in dangerous situations is your
concern that it would cause more
questioning at a critical time
when seconds count well clearly that's
going to be the result is that it would
cause maybe the loss of life maybe the
loss of officer life because there would
be hesitation less than a second on many
occasions Assemblyman Lackey says the
better solution here is to improve
police training this bill by the way is
likely to face stiff opposition from law
enforcement organizations their voices
carry a lot of weight here in Sacramento
Fionna they sure do Carter thank you